ci stiamo evolvendo ragazzi per adesso
mi posso bippare da solo quando dico
perché stronzo
per bippare
[Applauso]
sentirei ragazzo valido ci siamo da
nissim i redditi perché nel primo video
di rendite effettivamente avevo detto
che avresti avuto fare dei meme comunque
delle cose su reddit che io avrei potuto
commentare siccome non sono un
frequentatore di reddit diversamente da
tutti per un boomer di reddito che sono
un boom era quindi questo per me risulta
non semplicissimo ma ho visto che avete
postato un sacco di roba e quindi let's
go e vediamo che succede lorenzo ostuni
lorenzo
[Musica]
partiamo bene dai che saluterà il bene
francese a me ha sempre fatto ridere più
del dovuto e non so perché ragazzi sarà
però che twiggy quando li abbiamo fatto
un così 4 a 3 parigi che dice 1709 per
salutarli tutti persone che dicono a
fare primi saluti
in realtà ragazzi e non è servito a
niente perché comunque sembra che sia
una sorta di qik
le persone ce l'hanno a prescindere non
si sa perché vedevano la spesa similia
due etti di prosciutto risoluti
prosciutto e poi due di mozzarella
capocchia vries cambiamenti non so come
mai ragazzo si può fare niente lasciamo
perdere lorenzo saluta tutti in umido un
altro nome non c'è perché è raro esatto
quello che stavo dicendo io che apro il
frigo e realizzo che vuoto sapete
ragazzi che la cosa divertente è che ho
fatto talmente tante cose nella mia vita
che non so neanche da dove ripresa sta
scena cioè non so in quale video sia
giura uno squilibrio voci come sto messo
nella vita ti racconto un piccolo
aneddoto e fa molto ridere da altra
settimana praticamente stavo
messaggiando perché un ragazzo aveva
scritto io ho scritto a io studio a
bergamo e io alla grande e poi il giorno
dopo ma dove che studi lo scritto non mi
ricordo neanche i messaggi programma più
scritto ma ha fatto solo bene la vj
mette la matita sotto gli occhi ovvero
queste foto qui che va bè del 2017
[Musica]
avrete
beh
va beh sapevate che non bisogna per
forza studiare recitazione per fare un
film
arrivederci
o dj quando esce per fare una camminata
e veniva anche lo store calo da lontano
fa vj
diciamo che si non c'è stata una volta
negli ultimi anni in cui non mi si è
accorto tra l'altro riesco a fare
anticamera duals quelle che fa tipo non
so se conoscete zack e cody spero di sì
cody e si chiama cole sprouse l'attore
ha fatto 66 si chiama camera due
praticamente quando qualcuno lì scatta
una foto per strada lui a scatta prima è
un fenomeno e questa cosa ragazzi l'ho
fatto anch'io morale che bravo la faccio
vedere perché questo questa questa è
l'immagine noi zoomiamo qua eccolo
eccolo
proprio a lui però ho vinto io perché il
camera dove sistema di riuscire a farla
foto prima che scattino quindi stato
molto bravo io che cerco di fare tanti
nomi mese per far vincere fanno lavorare
nella serie dove adesso facciamo che hai
mi date una mano a fare la mia lavoro e
sono che prima erano qui facciamo i
videogiochi adesso no il secolo shaun
battibecco sai che sono tornato valori
un tempo è l'ora e prende la patente
sempre l'ora e leggi della strada
preparatevi essere ignorate ma sapete
che da quando ho preso la patente allora
il discorso è questo di non perdere la
patente ma vedevo la gente che vi dà a
prestare ma c'è una ciclo 15 ma
come non era normale questa cosa da
quando ho preso la patente il vento
sempre invece di nemici pc di cimici di
velocità sempre perché effettivamente
[Musica]
tra polizia la polizia che hanno capito
che ho detto ragazza nata la vera ma
vigenti aspetta f2p like uguale sono
esattamente come mi immagino domani c'è
domani prove domani non tra l'altro
entrandoci sono che posso squid game che
tu qui cerca le cose tipo adesso pratici
il game bello essere boomer di reddit
scopre un sacco di roba qui game show
meters quiz game for guys
mario shell dance perfection ior è
aggiunto anche un altro che ovviamente
poi sarebbe stato takeshi's castle
ragazzi io ho ancora sento gente che non
sa cos'è che come fatto lo scopo di
presentare hashish cast come fa la gente
ad aver vissuto come mai non è sui libri
di storia takeshi's cast ragazzi
veramente comunque e squibb game prima
di scappare veramente sui piedi solo che
è un po più family friendly mettiamola
così se non ci sarebbero stati voi
boomer a fare le petizioni quando
sicuramente che poi dove la caccia ma io
voglio vedere una petizione squid
infermi luce ma io veramente non ho capo
ad esso non so se sto sbagliando io però
di fronte allo sgomento di mamme e
maestre le scuole materne non bastano i
buoni propositi ma serve un'azione
concreta si legge nell'appello che
accompagna la petizione sulla
piattaforma cd punto hard firmata al
momento oltre 2.900 persone ragazzi ma
2.900 non sono niente luca ragazzi
questo era il video di oggi ho visto un
po degenerata pesa andati off topic i
proventi prossime saranno tutti tipo
cercare un suv land it andare off topic
immagino che faccia parte del gioco
comunque ragazzi bellissimo fatemi
sapere se volete altri due su reddit nel
caso trovate il mio saab reddit che fa
vj reddit di parigi e ray di the trovato
tutto fatemi sapere come l'audio perché
stiamo cercando e migliorarlo ma ci
saranno ancora altri miglioramenti
perché devo ammetter ancora un paio di
pannelli fonoassorbenti ho dovuto
raggiungere un compromesso perché io non
sono fan di questa roba qua lollo sempre
odiata però la voglio fare un po più di
video game o necessità di fare questo
change fatemi sapere se vi se mi aggrada
al cambiamento ma comunque migliorerà
ancora nei prossimi giorni quindi
previsione giusto si chiede a che l'hai
lasciato un bel commento è un piacere
era come sempre ci vediamo ad un
prossimo video e ragazzi
[Musica]